欢迎收听古爱,我是陈梦公
本期节目由真的茶赞助
自从上次在巴厘岛喝康普茶喝到上瘾
回家后就到处找来喝
这次跟大家介绍我的同乡
一样来自苗栗的真的茶
这个品牌是百年的制茶世家
近两年拿下欧美奖项
他们新出了两款东方美人茶饮康普茶跟气泡茶
一开始我以为是典型认知中的茶
结果完全不是
保留了茶的细腻
喝起来又有一点像香槟自然酒
香气会慢慢随着时间跟温度产生变化
首先是Lis
东方美人气泡茶
它不靠强烈的气泡去刺激你
而是用很细又绵密的气泡
把茶香一层一层往上推
它用了比一般市售更高比例的茶叶去做萃取
所以第一口就可以闻到热带水果的香气
那接着是东方美人很经典的蜜香
再慢慢的带出白花香
我自己很喜欢它放个几分钟之后
再来喝温度稍微上来一点
香气又变成另一种样子
另外一个
Sell Kuth
东方美人康普茶
很多人听到康普茶第一个反应就是酸
但是它一样不是走刺激的路线
而是用两款东方美人茶一起供酿
把茶香放在前面
发酵放在后面
入口先是手果跟蜜香
中间慢慢带出青梅的酸甜感
再往后喝还会跑出一点荔枝跟酒红玫瑰的香气
它很像一只风味完整的饮品
让你了解到原来茶经过时间跟发酵之后
也可以有这么多的层次
这一次推出的组合跟价钱是专属给古牌听众
而真的茶品牌主理人都是长期资深矮保
这一次为了各位Chika准备了一款寻香杯专属礼物
买4瓶以上的组合就送
只送不卖
一盒两路的台湾制造超美手工玻璃杯
如果有兴趣的可以到我们资讯栏找到更多的说明与连结
好那这件事是充满了那种沧海桑田的味道
又持续的感觉自己年纪慢慢变大
虽然我在节目里面很像很常有这样子的感叹
我只能够说好像过了30岁之后很多事情进展的太快
有些是令你措手不及的
首先就是在非常严格的运动训练
跟持续的减重的状况之下
我现在的睡眠品质直接变得很好
像我老婆讲说
我已经是完全不会打呼了
她也觉得非常的意外
再来就是我现在可能
每天的11点12点
就会直接准时而倒地
然后5点多6点
就会准时的醒来
接着会干嘛
就突然间你也不知道为什么
不知道是Nature Calling
还是祖灵跟你讲了什么
你就跟你的阿公一样
你开始在床上去做伸展
我們家人出去住飯店的時候老婆講說馬勒被你吵死了一早在那邊伸展你不會跑去別的房間或什麼的我就突然間想到說以前我老公好像是這樣就是可能半夜就跑起來然後就會去做一些奇怪的事情
像我爸的話
就是你半夜會聽到他跑起來
然後一直去弄塑膠袋
不知道在弄嗎
一時就
就很多那種聲音跑出來
結果我自己家裡
變成是這樣子的長輩了
只是我可能還沒有去弄塑膠袋
但我就會起床
就開始去做一些伸展之類的
然後再來就是看到
自己的孩子交的一些朋友
現在開始在心中
也會有一點
當然我們不希望成為一個討人厭的大人
給太多意見
但是我必須得講
觀感跟感受這件事情是存在的
所以覺得說他在兒童遊樂區
你看到他被欺負
你就會覺得說你不爽那個小孩
雖然小孩都是小孩
你相信他們是天正無邪的
你講說他爸媽在哪
到底有沒有看著之類
或是你孩子跟你講說他喜歡的朋友
然後他家喜歡的女生是怎麼樣
你心中也會稍微有一把尺在那邊打分數
那你也開始去懂得說
為什麼以前可能跟你爸爸媽講什麼
然後他們會感覺到出來吐槽你有什麼
因為你自己身為爸媽
你就知道說你還是會有反應
你看你孩子
雖然他的生活他自己可以去做主張
我們只需要去做輔導
但你就真的會產生一些想法
只是我自己會盡量希望不要像
可能前一代的家長
就是會去做蠻多的紀錄
我會希望說我的態度是
你爸一定是為了你好
但是你爸不會告訴你要怎麼做
我會告訴你說我的想法
那接著就讓你自己做判斷
那我也要真的相信他
讓他去做判斷
即便我知道他會落賽或什麼的
你還是要讓他自己去
因為這樣可能才不會
把自己的孩子給趕跑
以後都不敢跟你講
再來在自己的工作上面
最近有一些蠻神奇的想法
因為就看到
像在Telegram裡面
有人要tag我聊天的時候
然後就有提到說
夢工以前是怎麼起來的
就那種很老梗
已經被問了好幾年的問題
其實你們就往前聽
以前的急速就是了
其實不同的階段去聽我的節目
可能會有不一樣的想法
不然說可能
因為我現在跟早期的自己比起來
也差很多了
所以其實當然每個人
可能都會找到適合自己的
某一個片段
但總之我沒有要去取悅
任何人的意思
就是很如實的去分享自己
在工作跟一些可能在交易跟投資上面的想法
像以前我很常跟大家講的一件事情
就是說我年輕的時候真的是比較充一點
各種槓桿能用的就用爆
我的態度是什麼
就死而算了
這個老聽眾應該要背得出來
最近就是因為有一些新的聽眾在問我這樣的東西
在tag我
當然我是懶得去回這種東西
因為就是媽媽隨時都有新的聽眾
不可能每次都幫你去複習
但是有些聽眾就會幫我回答
就說他就是那種槓桿槓爆
然後死而算了
拼一發大的或什麼的
可是這時候我就突然間想跑出來揭露一下
我就想說其實我看現在的年輕人
或這些少年古神當然我自己也沒有到多老就是34歲只是新一代的這些年輕人現在大家開始聽到一些很有趣的字什麼四代同堂然後在什麼槓上加槓或什麼突然發現說
以前我們真的算超保守
就是以前我那時候在節目跟大家講說
我這種算風險很大嘛
那一些人聽到可能覺得說
你隨時會暴躁什麼的
其實我們的風險程度跟那些人比
真的是差超級遠的
然後再來就是像我自己有被吹剿過
可是我從來沒有給人家什麼斷頭什麼的
我都會自己去做處理
那之後後來就發現說
現在新一代的蠻多好像被斷頭是蠻正常的事情
我突然間爆掉
然後接著很快又再站回來
對他們來講說叫做家常便飯
也就是現在的年輕人真的有一種那種
Too fast to live too young to die的那種感覺
就是他就是跟你媽的拚了死了算了
所以他們那種才是真正的死了算了
就是我們已經是某個程度上
被掃去隔壁的老人家了
所以當有人在可能回答那些新的聽眾說
他以前的態度是比較偏像說死了算了
衝槓桿槓滿
我說其實我以前最大的時候
大概也就是槓2.5倍左右
融資開滿最後是這樣
有些東西我一買反映說
原來你不能夠融資
我就不買了
我意思是說可能我前面在做研究
然後最後沒有要買的時候
發現說他沒有辦法融資
就直接不買了
因為代表我槓開不上去
可是最多
因為你槓桿開滿的話
以融資來講就是你自備款是4成
你可以買到10成的股票
就是2.5倍
所以我最大的就是2.5倍
當然往下掉的時候
代表你的槓桿倍數會變大
可是就差不多在這個範圍裡面
因為你都會提早去做一些處理
像這樣子的槓桿背數
其實在新一代的這些股民裡面
大家會聽到什麼四代同堂
古旗槓爆
或是什麼選擇權弄爆
或是不停的roll
什麼叫roll呢
就是因為像你古旗去買
你買滿
你把保證金都用光
上漲之後保證金回充
就可以繼續再買
不然如果你是融資的話
也蠻流行
就是很多人這樣一路融資上去
接著你漲到某個地方
他就把他東西先充掉
然後接著再融一次回去
就把額度調高再幹上去
所以其實現在有很多人
是在用一個超級充的方式
在做事情
那我絕對不會想要去當一個老人家
在那邊跟大家提醒什麼風險
因為我覺得風險大家自己要知道
不知道的就早晚也會被抬出去
所以跟他多說也無意
但必須得說
我想要稍微的修正一下
其實我們真的不算是一個高風險的人
以前我也跟大家講說
就是我可能在做一些比較高風險的操作
但是在新一輩的這些股民裡面
我那個算是超級保守
所以以後可能就是保守派投資人
就算你問我早期怎麼樣
我也說我相對保守
因為那時候最多就是融資開門
不相信他這麼多花招
一大堆人可能先去用自己的
企業識別證信貸
然後貸了之後再進去再融資或是股息或什麼的所以隨便算一算他的槓桿的比例都是可能五六倍以上超級恐怖的像這樣子超級大的槓桿或是那種不停漏上去的它基本上只要遇到
大概一兩根跌停
就有機會可以直接把整個部位
upditorate了掉
整個就會被掃掉
聽起來是非常誇張 非常嚇人
跟在我的心目中
或是像其實身邊有一些朋友
也討論過這件事情
當大家知道說
現在蠻多新一代人這樣搞的時候
大家都很意外
就是你怎麼可能可以這樣子搞
因為這樣子理論上是
是沒有辦法sustain下去
是會出問題的
但就真的很多人靠這樣子
然後在短期間就發了很大的一筆財
所以相對之下
真的以前的自己一點都不算是高風險
所以以前會講說
怎麼自己可能是高風險操作出來的
我現在就不會這樣講
就現在可能就要稍微改口
所以這也是時代不一樣
並不是說我們換了位置換了腦袋
或者說什麼去改說法
是你在外面真的看到說
會越來越多那一種
就是你無法想像的事情
然後讓你過去的那些東西
都變得好像是沒什麼
就再說像最近一個
令我非常震撼的
我相信我應該有這節目跟大家分享
就是巴菲特他一定沒有想過
他有照一日會變成一種單位
就是馬斯克的SpaceX上市之後
他一天的震盪就是一個巴菲特
什麼意思
巴菲特賺一輩子的錢
身為投資界最強大的人
一輩子的錢加起來
就是馬斯克一天的震盪而已
所以對就是時代變了
當然相信每一代都一定會越來越好
我們不是那一種就是
我也會覺得什麼現在的九年級
有什麼00後的怎麼樣
我也最討厭這樣
因為以前我們也會被人家說什麼
八年級的什麼草莓竹我啥小的
沒有必要這樣一代逗一代
每一代都會玩出新的把戲
所以也盡量不要去講說什麼
新一代的年輕人看太多短影音就很笨
你就想當年我們爸媽還講說
你看一堆港片
你看一堆YouTube你會變笨
那到底是誰笨
所以我相信年輕人都是一代比一代好
就算他們可能去做一些
非常高風險的事情
但可能就是這一代年輕人
他們不知道某個程度上會經過的路
有些人就會靠這個
在短期間可能就累積到巨大的財富
當然一定會有很多被掃下去的
可是這個也沒什麼好講的
就像是可能一堆人跑去
準備學測聯考或什麼小的
也不是說每個人都一定可以念到好學校
花一堆錢投資也不一定可以
真的就考到不錯的學校
或者說去國外念個學歷回來
也不是每個都一定成功
去工作去投資其實都一樣
只是我還是會覺得
如果你是我聽眾的話
我希望你多多想一下自己跟你的家人
如果說你今天為了貪快
你衝一發大的
這個是有可能他的當賽是有機會把你掃掉
或是讓你們全家進入一個負債地獄的話
你要三思
不要只想到說upside
你要去想一下downside
然後再來就是慢慢來比較快
其實還是我後來蠻喜歡的一個座右銘
他不是一個最核心的
但是我會很常把這個東西
放進去我的思維裡面
就是盡量讓自己慢下來
除了是我自己本身算是非常急性質的人
所以我知道說慢下來對我來說會更好
就是一些東西可以看得更仔細
比較不會有一些衝動的行為之外
然後再來就是
你會發現你最終可能都會到某些地方
但你在過程之中
假設你看到一些很快的人
你也想跟著貪快的話
你是有機會讓自己爆炸
但你有機會很快
可是問題是你拿什麼去換
就如果說你是慢慢的上去
你們全家都不會受影響
如果說你快快上去
你是有可能全家會受影響
所以這個還是大家自己要小心
總之就突然間覺得說
就是我們自己以前的一些認知
後來都被顛覆掉了
除了自己當爸之外
然後再就是隨著
貸款的管道越來越多
槓桿的工具越來越發達
真的很多東西都跟自己想的
是不太一樣
稍微抒發一下自己的想法
好 接下來我們來進入市場話題
那今天的台股尾盤
就開始有一些中小就轉強了
跟過去的幾天比起來
算是終於有一點拉尾
但其實有蠻多的型態
我覺得就是做的有點不好看
所以跟前面的兩集的觀點還是一樣
如果說有些東西是掉到季線以下的
我感覺就會轉弱
我就覺得說大哥可能就要換人當了
再來如果有些東西是掉到季線附近
就直接往上
甚至是像以台股的功率族群來講的話
基本上都還在五日線跟十日線
就是可能市場上面的一個主流
但現在這些東西
可能稍微有一些比較tricky的地方
因為過去一個比較大的族群
然後可以塞很多錢的是被動元件
因為被動元件最大的
可能像國劇華新科或什麼的
法人是有辦法可以parking進去的
可是像功率元件的話
一些比較強勢的主流股
他們的market cap大概是落在數百億左右
這什麼意思呢
就是說那些比較大型的法人
應該是沒有辦法把錢放到這裡面
所以就算功率元件可能在市場上面
算是一個相對強勢的族群
只是我自己還是會想再去規劃一些
額外的族群去想說
有沒有可能後面哪些是法人會衝進去的
因為法人總是要找個地方去
當然有可能就是被動元件在後面
就繼續反彈然後就再繼續往上走
那只是按照自己的經驗
一般來講
就如果說拉回到這樣一個程度
他會需要橫盤去做一下整理
目前的盤面
最近當然也會有一些朋友
會想要去討論去問
有些人想說這個盤勢要怎麼樣解
其實我覺得根本沒什麼好解
因為你去看一下加權指數
基本上就在右上角
所以這邊沒什麼要討論的
簡單來說就是可能中小這邊
出現了一些比較大的震盪
至於是什麼原因
我覺得也不用太細就了
我個人認為現在要我猜的話
應該就是一個蠻劇烈的降槓行為
就是類似說可能我們看到韓谷那樣因為韓國股市就整天在那邊壟斷韓國股市你可以想像是一個非常speculative的一個市場非常投機裡面就是一堆人在可能使用大量的槓桿去搞股票
然後跟
甚至他們國家的一些政府單位人員
都有提到說他們的槓桿ETF
實在是太盛行
這個就是韓國的一個現狀
其實我們在過去也看過很多次
就不管他們跑去炒什麼Tesla
Parentier或是加密貨幣或什麼
反正每次只要最後面韓國人群聚的地方
就是會被玩壞掉
就是會完成大賭場
只是他們現在要回去
把自己國家的指數完成大賭場
差不多是這樣的一個感受
因為最近韓國在降槓
所以我覺得可能就是那一種
可能比較偏向投機的氣息
在最近是有一點被掐掉
不然說我們在前幾集
有跟大家聊到說
最近如果去追強
很高機率就是你會被修理
你就直接被修理
因為可能短期轉強的東西
隔天就會直接轉弱
然後就把你殺爆
那些可能去追這些強勢古人
他們的習慣的做法
就像我們剛剛前面所提到的
他就一次把槓桿打滿
所以他基本上是扛不了任何的回檔
只要任何的回檔
他就必須要亂殺
所以你會在一些古期會注意到說
甚至是可能它的現股
明明就還在3 5%左右的一個區間
就跌這樣而已
可是它的古期竟然跑去摸跌停
那就是因為有很多人槓桿槓爆
所導致的一個比較劇烈的波動
所以我覺得在韓股
你可以想像成是一個完全體
那台股可能就是一個比較縮小的版本
所以我自己目前會先這樣去猜
因為我在市場上沒有找到
可能夠大的壞消息
可以去justify
就最近的這樣的一些回檔
然後再來就是
雖然即便有一些族群開始
摔破季限 轉落什麼的
但是其實強勢族群在市場上都還是有
除了剛剛提到的功率之外
像是CCL也都還很強
Wafer也都還很強
所以其實是有很多強勢族群在市場上的
這個不太像是行情要在短期內立刻結束的樣子
它只像是一個新一波的輪動產生
像光是直接集體轉弱
在被動元件下有蠻多也進入了修正
所以就是可能換下個東西
這樣的一個味道才是
我覺得是市場的一個主軸
當然每個人會有自己不一樣的判斷
這個都尊重大家
我就稍微的分享一下自己的一些小小的看法
最近市場上當然有很多人在講說
可能這一波的修正完全是被Semi Analysis 刊出來的
這個機構
其實我們最早大概在2023 2024的時候
就跟大家聊到他們
那時候我自己本身也是他們的一個店戶
後來不是覺得他們不好
我覺得他們的作品真的蠻不錯
跟那個DLEN其實我們也有聊過天
只是我心中的想法是覺得
後來簡單來講就是AI的一些Edge
已經不用去透過這些報告就可以去做取得
因為有時候是他們可能知道一些東西我不知道
所以我會去做訂閱
後來其實基本上都已經算是
全開圖的一個狀態
就是你要問的所有東西
基本上問得到甚至有時候它並不是說資訊落差的問題就像說像NVIDIA就是一個超級便宜的標的這個連講都不用講大家都知道但這是一個市場喜好度的問題大家要不要去推
所以很有趣的現象
像它在台股和美股都有類似的狀況
就是AI最核心的東西
以台股來講絕對就是TSMC
以美股來講絕對就是NVIDIA
可是兩個東西卻是交易在最便宜的估值
他們的一些快樂好朋友
反而他的交易層數是高很多
你說為什麼會這樣
其實你也難以去做解釋
所以過去可以取得的一些
所謂消息的alpha或什麼的
我後來發現在訂閱的報告裡面
比較拿不到
所以我就沒有再去做訂閱
但是他們發的一些文章或什麼的
還是會稍微的有看到這樣
我必須得說
當然可能是因為它在市場上累積了夠長一段的
算是蠻有Credit的一個影響力
然後他們最近快速的把這個Credit燒掉
對 簡單來講就是
我們過去也注意到一些機構
或者一些報告他們會做類似的事情
他們在過去可能累積了蠻大的一個信譽
最後可能就是
也不好說人家是膨脹
就是你可能當你今天
對某些東西的掌握度高到一個程度之後
大家可能就不會甘於說
只是去講產業的某一些新的發展
像我們節目就是因為
我曾經被一些空投給教宣過
你發現空投會有很多人跑出來反應
所以最後面我們就是只聚焦去講一些
可能長期產業的東西
越遠招這東西基本上很難錯
反正就是說趨勢抓對
重點只是找到好的買點而已
那就不會想要去做任何的摸頭或什麼的
因為基本上你去講一下股票空或什麼的
那個最後面都會引起非常大的爭議
就是會出問題
會被燒到
所以像我們自己是非常去注意這一點
我們就只講產業長期的一些需求跟發展這樣
只是有蠻多那種延調組織
我覺得可能就是因為過去累積了
蠻強大的一些實力
他們一開始也不一定是有惡意或什麼的
或是我也不是講說什麼
某些機構他就是惡意
但他就會在心中覺得
可能目前他知道市場上的預期是什麼東西
這個預期他認為會miss
所以他就是把這個認為會miss的東西講出來
可是一般如果你有仔細去看他們的報告
你就會發現它裡面一定都會有一個淡書
就是會告訴你說
雖然是這樣
但是可能Big Picture是不改變
可是問題是這個時代
大家去取用資訊的做法是
其實很多人都直接看標題
就他不一定會回去看你的內文
他光是看了標題之後
他可能就把它轉出去
然後或是
就直接被人家去做刺激的封裝
包裝完之後
然後就再灑出去
這個其實我自己也是
蠻常受害於這樣子
就是我覺得說
如果你都是有來聽節目的聽眾
其實你應該會聽得出來
就是我在每一個東西的語意上
或是一些情緒的表達上
某個程度上
我看到說是某一種
就是類似參數跟訊號之類的
當然不是說什麼
我要給市場一些暗示我只是說你如果有去認真聽你就會知道說雖然我們可能提到了10個東西可是這10個東西你的評價或是你的樂觀跟悲觀程度其實是不一樣但有些人會想要用量化去刷你的東西
所以他就會去貼說
古埃自己講到的標的
就即便那些東西
很多時候我自己看到
原來我有提到這個
我可能只是隨口提
可是在他的權重看起來是一樣的
所以一樣的道理就是
如果你今天只去看標題
就會掉入這樣的一個陷阱
就會類似說他前面剛發生
是在講說CPU跟800VDC的一個延遲
其實裡面並不是真的寫得非常bearish
就是比較偏向說
我認為是在講地顏這件事情
而且後來我們在節目有跟大家分享說
Dian Patel他在一個X的推文下面有講到
他其實認為那個滲透率只有5%
然後5%對他兩次不好
可是那時候我們在節目講我自己的看法
其實5%叫很好
因為我們甚至會去買一堆
根本你在一兩年內看不到營收的東西
大家都會買了
所以你有5%的滲透率
那已經算是非常好
所以你就會知道說
如果你有認真的去剖析的話
你會得出一些不一樣的想法
但我覺得現在市場就是一個蠻速食的狀態
然後跟很多資訊跑得很快
所以嚴格上來說
你要說是Semi Analysis
他發一些報告把東西打下去
還是說是月聽人自己完全是沒有Faith
然後他只要看到任何的風吹草動
就想要亂賣東西
到底是哪個對市場影響比較大
其實我覺得是後者
但是大家一定會怪給前者
所以其實我猜啦
他們最近應該就會遇到一些問題
就一定的
因為你影響的市場太大了
然後你都在很關鍵的時間點
丟出一些很有爭議的東西
然後大家就會把所有的問題
都指到你身上
然後就會讓你變得很敏感
可能就因為這樣會接受到一些調查
就是可能會產生一些問題
因為大家會抱老鼠鴻
還記不記得之前中國那邊有一個分析師
雖然我們蠻常提到
但我們現在就不要去提了
就是三個英文字的
那他那時候就只是去講一下
自己對光通元件的一些看法
然後最後面就直接給人家人露出來
甚至反正就聽說有發生一些不好的事情
所以就直接把所有東西都收掉
就一樣的道理
真的市場上超多人會抱老鼠鴻的
所以我覺得他們現在就是偏危險
但是我們一樣就稍微的剖析一下看法
一般我們都是用比較中心的方式
就是我們像過去在評論他講的
什麼CPU800V的延遲
我們也不會直接說什麼
那個阿三在亂講
因為像網上一堆說那個阿三在亂講
沒有啦 就是我們還是去剖析一下
到底實際上等一下講什麼東西
盡量不要用一些情緒的用語
因為如果說我覺得
其實你要思考是為什麼
隨便一個消息可以把一些東西打下去
是不是上面真的福而多了
就是如果說真的是非常好的東西的話
其實它在過程中
比較不會遇到一些有的沒有的亂流
就算有遇到的話
其實對絕大多數人來說
你想買的就是一個買點的製造
只是因為現在剛好行情可能是比較震盪
一些中小回比較大
所以大家就會
類似說就是一定要去抓一個戰犯
剛好就抓不長眼的
在不對的時間丟不對的東西的人
實際上他的東西都有一些silverlining的存在
就若若所說
不然說他們前面曾經提到
Solcam的需求崩潰論
或者說micron的HBM4
可能沒有做不進去之類
最後面就發現說
那其實都是在講一個很短的東西
所以套一個我產業朋友他講的東西
他說其實大家搞不清楚
technology跟product的一個差別
這個我們在節目也是多次跟大家溝通
這樣的概念
其實現在蠻多人是在trade RD project
什麼意思
就是一個東西他還在實驗跟研發的時候
市場就因為高度的預期先把它炒上去
然後接著再因為說
這個東西可能沒有辦法
如期的量產而殺下來
但是如果你今天是站在公司派的角度
他們的想法是
我這個東西我從頭到尾都還沒登場過
所以你們自己在那邊自嗨
然後自嗨完之後
又自己把東西殺下來
可是時間到了就是我產品該推出來
就還是會推出來
所以其實像之前不知道大家記住
一兩年前那時候
GB200大家在講起REX的時候
最早市場上是喊說
一年可以做到7萬還10萬REX
當時我們節目講說
一定不會是這個數字
應該說也不是只有我們有什麼獨到的know how
就是你真的有在看的就知道一定不是這個數字
可是就不知道為什麼市場上有人在傳那個數字
然後最後面下調的時候
就是大家開始去醒來
發現說其實不會這麼高
股價崩下來
然後大家就會講說
你看所以就是什麼
有人在打擊啊或什麼什麼
但其實不是
那個是因為大家自己把預期跌得太高
所以它某個程度上在做的事情
我覺得是有點在幫大家做壓力測試
只是我覺得就一樣
當兵都有教過
不打琴 不打懶 只打不長眼
就是可能在不對的時間點
然後你看那種X上面
或者說什麼Reddit
只要有燒起來在燒你
那個可能就真的會變得很大條
就大家可能真的跑去SEC舉報之類的
就可能被調查
那這次就在講說
Kyber NVL 144
可能會發生遞延的一個狀態
因為可能Midplan的一個製造困難等等
但這個東西
如果說你去回聽我們節目
就是我們以前也有跟大家講過這件事情
就是我們講那個證交背板
就是Kyber那個Midplan
因為它是要用PTFE材料
然後跟Q
就是說Q部跟PTFE的材料
後來應該是會去做一個混搭
如果說存用PTFE或是存用Q的話
一個是可能成本的問題
一個是說可能因為熱度太高
會導致有些材料會溶掉的一些問題
所以它本來發展就還在
怎麼講 都演你中 還在測試中
其實在現在我們都還是有看到
像中國的盛紅是有持續測這一塊料
只是當然它可能預計是會搭配VR Rubin一起出來然後這邊發現說就是一直去往後延有些人講說Rubin Ultra然後現在甚至講說就可能不會跟著Rubin Ultra會到飛門才會跑出來但這個你說它是一個新聞嗎
就像我在臉書跟大家講
它其實真的不是新聞
因為在產業看得到一些
延調或是一些報告的
其實本來就知道說這個東西
它不會像之前大家想像的
這麼快出來
再不記得你聽我們節目
我們也是有跟大家聊到說
就是它的Kyber怪物REC
就是可能會有一些敵人的狀況
包含說那時候我們去跟大家分享說
在Computex看到的東西的時候
就有去提到這一段
當然不知道要去講說
你看說我們消息比他快有什麼
我只能夠說這個其實在投資圈裡面
算是某個程度上的一種共識
就是你很難想像有人會期待
你可以立刻看到這個東西
它本來就是一個
可能還是比較偏向是實驗階段的東西
只是看什麼時候要把它拿出來
所以如果你認真去看
Semi-Analysis最近幾個
可能比較有爭議的文章
就會發現說
他講的東西都是比較偏向是
他要去修正一些短期的樂觀的預期
但是長線是不改變
包括像前面提到什麼HBM
Solcam 記憶體用量或是800VDC
或這次的Kyber144的某一種delay
他其實某個程度上就是
你可以想像成就
有點像我們之前會吐槽的
CNN恐懼貪婪指標
到現在真的有人宣稱用那個做股票
怎麼可能
一下樂觀一下悲觀
你做啥小
就一樣的道理
就是你沒有辦法在短期內
去靠大量這樣子 rumor
或者說消息的東西去
當然有可能就是在一些時間點
有機會賺到錢
可是長期來看
我覺得是沒有什麼太大意義的事情
因為它並沒有造成一些
產業發展的巨大的變動
它只能夠說是有點像是說
今天你知道整個班上
整個教室
大家都是很期待說
同樂會會在 7月10號發生
然後突然間講說
因為颱風所以變7月12號
差不多這樣的感受
就是同樂會是會發生的
只是有一個同學跑進來跟大家講說
同樂會不會發生
因為我這邊有辦法看到颱風的路徑
是怎樣
最後面可能真的證明說
這位同學是對的
可是就如我所說
因為你就是惹到人了
惹到人就是可能
就是我覺得會被處理掉
大家一定會去抱老鼠淵
但也只能夠說佩服他的勇氣
蠻趕出來的在市場上講這些東西
因為像我們自己如果知道
有些東西發生一些帝人或什麼
一般我們都會用比較保守的
心態去跟大家講
像可能過去有時候在QA
大家問一些東西
我如果覺得是沒有這麼正向的
我就會講說不方便評論或是怎麼樣
可是畢竟人家還是做言調的
所以他可能只是把他認為是對的東西講出來但就如果說這個東西就是應該會惹到一些人但總之結論就是這幾個報告看下來
當然有些人會把它當成是
某種末日報告來看
我只能夠說那些月天人的數值
可能也還不夠
因為嚴格上來說
他提到的東西都只能夠算是
可能在一個產業發展之中的
一些短期的逆風
或者是說一些Pathfinding
可能在過程中
不小心撞到牆
繞個彎過去
但是該發生該有的事情
其實最終都會發生
所以並不會因為說這些報告
而導致一些毀滅性的改變
或什麼的
就是根本就是沒有
所以只能夠說
因為現在可能盤面的狀況就是不好
所以這些東西被拿出來
放大解讀跟說明
那當然我也不知道要幫他擦脂抹粉
因為我自己講
他這樣的做法一定會惹到一些問題
但實際上就是他講的東西
就類似說看你怎麼樣去解讀
800VDC
可能到現在還是很多人會認為說
你看就像他講的
要怎麼樣要BARBQ
可是可能我們就是樂觀派的
我們就覺得說不會啊
明年5%很好啊
所以這個是一個正向的訊號
或是Kyber可以在飛門
搞不好我們還覺得這樣很好啊
因為其實我們身邊有一些朋友
甚至聽到說搞不好
你知道就是有一些那種很酷的架構的東西
說不定它一輩子都沒有登場的機會
所以你告訴我它還會在飛門登場
那我覺得也挺好的
所以其實本來就是這些可能公司
或是發展中的AI大企業
他們就是會有很多路徑的一些嘗試
然後在過程中
你很常會聽到一些上修下修
或者說整個東西的地言
或是說什麼POIN什麼的
但嚴格上來說
某種上都是一些NOISES
都是一些雜音
所以要關注的重點是什麼
我覺得第一個就是
還是大的趨勢要抓到
所以當然AI的類股持續的去做
不管是布局或做切換
這個一定是我們的核心指導原則
再來就是去關注資金的一個走向
也是非常的重要
所以有時候是這樣子
就是一些族群可能只是剛好
它搭配一些不好的消息
或甚至是一些不好的時間點
剛好把它打下去
那它的形態也做壞掉
它其實長線來看說不定
一切都是no change
高機率都是no change
只是短期上就不一定會動
所以就類似說
可能我們前面跟大家聊到說
像這波的修正
有些東西直接掉到季線下面
你說掉到季線下面
我們就不去點名
一些也是那種巨頭公司
他們不好也沒有不好
就一定也是好的
在產業上一定也不錯
可是市場是這樣
大家對於一些風吹吵動是比較敏感
所以會想去找可能比較強勢的東西去搞
所以這也是為什麼我們會
除了去看一些基本面的東西
我們為什麼會對市場的一些線型
或是那些資金也都會去做一些剖析的原因就在這邊因為你總是要去抓的時候大家會往哪去大家都知道說有些東西掉下去它要再拉回來它就是重重賣壓為什麼我要去拉這個它可能就跑去拉別的東西所以以我們的角度來講我反而不會太糾結說
它唱壞什麼東西
我的看法反而是
好 既然它真的有唱壞一些東西
然後那些東西掉下去
然後真的就起不來了
可能就代表說
就算它沒有講這個東西
說不定在某個時間點
它也會掉下去
因為一定是上面的籌碼
沒有這麼好的
才會是這樣的一個情形
但可能整理之後
就還會有下一波
但我們要做的
我們要做的不是要去預言未來
其實在這個行情的判斷上
一般我們真的都是建造拆造
所以具體來說
像我們剛剛前面有提到說
像我們注意到一些強勢的東西
可以放大資金的
可能CCL Welfare
或是一些封測
一些強勢的族群
可是沒有辦法放大資金
可能就功率
被動元件的話
現在要蠻多進度修正
可是至少還在紀限上
這些東西對我們來說就是一個
簡單來說我在AI
我這麼多牌可以打
那我到底要去加碼哪一個
這其實就是看每個人的策略
其實有些人買左側的
他反而覺得像我前面講說
我自己也不想碰我的技術線效的東西
他買得很高興
因為反正對他來講
他的horizon是看更遠的
最後面會上去就好了
我也不想要整天在那邊trade
整天在那邊trade
你看最近在那邊做動能的
不是每個都被修理嗎
我就慢慢接
反正我知道他後來好
那也沒事
所以簡單講就是
我覺得都是有點那種
反正傭人自擾
當然在某些時間點
市場的一些雜訊
他可能就會對市場造成一些影響
與其去花時間糾結說是誰害的
怎麼講
我們自己或是我自己身邊
我覺得相對強的人
比較少做這種事情
因為你去炒這個沒有意義啊
就是那到底現在還有什麼牌可以打
是這樣
那如果今天真的是發現說沒有牌可以打了
那真的就要去小心說
有一些可能系統性風險就要出現了
所以像去年的三四月
就是一個很經典的
那時候不是我講說
美國人到底會不會做股票
那時候就是有很強這樣的一個感受
因為你真的已經在市場上
找不到族群可以做
那個時候蠻多時候就是要BBQ
就當你發現已經沒有任何的主流存在
那最近雖然有一些中小修正的非常嚴重
可是目前看都還是有
所以其實不會到非常悲觀
我覺得還是去觀察一下
看TSM後面出來講
是什麼樣的一個狀態
雖然可能市場上的一些預期數字是比較高
但好在最近的盤面也是比較正
所以還好
就如果說可能你覺得說
最近是已經到右上角去了
那剛好開出來的數字
即便它是好的
但就像剛剛前面所講到的
那一堆市場仔預期超級高
也不知道哪裡天來的數字
然後在那邊屌殺亂殺之類的
所以目前還是比較偏向中性
然後跟相對多去做看待
我覺得可能也是跟資金的隨位是有關係的
因為像我之前跟大家分享
就是以現在的券商來講
基本上都是已經在封控了
他們不讓你去做更多的借貸
過往的打法是
反正我只要壓對的
我就會持續的去
透過直壓的方式
去把槓桿放大
可是這種4月之後
我就一路被鎖掉
鎖到現在
就是我根本沒有辦法動
就是我也沒有東西去做加碼了
可能前面買的東西
成本也低了
所以甚至是說那種回檔出來
我根本也都沒有什麼感覺
我只覺得說
不知道可能下午看
網球教練可以打之類的
就這樣吧
因為你還能夠做什麼
反正對你來說成本拉遠
你真的也沒有什麼事情可以做
但如果就再說
就是現在是像過往一樣
就是這個融資或是說直壓額度
並沒有卡住我的話
最主要直壓
那我可能就是
也會有一些降槓桿的操作
那個勢必是這樣
所以其實真的是跟
每個人瞎的那個狀態跟水位有關係
所以可能我覺得
這陣子之所以會比較chill的原因
是因為你根本沒有辦法上槓
所以像這陣子
我們身邊其實真的超多人在
這陣子去做減碼
或甚至有些人就退出不做
開始去放暑假
但我就真的覺得沒有什麼感覺
因為根本就沒有辦法
在可能前面
就是可能相對高位的時候
你有錢去做加碼
你也沒錢了
你整個都已經打滿了
你只能夠去做一些微調
一些族群在輪動的時候
稍微調一點
但沒有辦法大額的加碼
或者說去上槓
所以導致說
你好像也不知道要調整什麼
所以有可能我之所以
現在節目聽起來比較chill是這樣
因為我觀察一下
好像這一波很多人很緊張
可是我就覺得
好像真的是還好
沒有這麼特別的情形
所以可能還是要在後面再看下去
至少在這波的修正
我們不敢說完全結束了
但如果說沒有去破前滴
在外面就持續往上拉的話
那就是去關注
剛剛前面所提到
可以放大錢的族群
然後跟相對強在
無日跟實際上的族群
如果他們都持續供新高的話
我覺得市場就是還沒有走完
大概是這樣
雖然最近開始越來越多人在討論的時候
是不是行情到這邊要結束
一樣 邊走邊看
那個沒有辦法事前去做一些預判
就算預判到也沒意義
因為後來發現說
那種會宣稱自己可能預判到這是高點的
他們過去一定是已經講了十幾次說
這個地方是高點
總而為是會給它賽掉
所以當預言家是沒有什麼太大的意涵的事情
大概這樣
接下來我們就Q的部分
第一位 純水英子
嗨夢宮大哥
你知道嚴厲斥責跟你發瘋啦嗎
還有對啦對啦對啦
最後一個不知道
前面兩個有聽過
下面一位 哀真實獵人
分享上次句
鎮靜舒眠的大場景
被捅到身體前後移動的時候
我有半夢半醒很有趣
推薦各位想被夢宮起卡鋼的指南
可以體驗看看
不太可能吧
那個針打下去
我身邊每個朋友
還有一些長輩分享
都是pass out
我也pass out
整個掛掉
最好我是有辦法感受得到太怪了吧下面一位夢工大您好大概從去年10月開始進入股市每个月听您说绩效大暴社但自己经营出出最后发现自己还是比较适合指数投资但您的节目还是使人获益良多
常跟我先生听到笑出来
月底跟我的先生要去美国了
希望一切顺利也祝您绩效继续长红
另外我先生Ray
7月9号生日可以请您跟他说那四个字吗
谢谢爱您 恭喜发财
再来讲说绩效大暴社
其實我們真的不是那種會去吹自己績效
或是怎麼樣的人
就是如實地去分享
像落賽也都是會跟大家講
我知道大多數去分享股市的
都喜歡講自己多會賺
但其實我們剛好是相反
甚至有時候我自己會故意提爆
我是覺得沒有必要去惹上一些麻煩
反正我們可以在這邊透過一些分享
我自己也可以獲得一些資訊
這個對我來講是最重要的事情
只是老實講
今年上半年是非常誇張的上半年
大家記得我記得跟大家講過
兩個少年股神
那時候我記得他泡茶
這兩個少年股神都已經是變成是
一過往來講就是大戶等級
他們兩個都已經是長成大戶了
他們也不是在市場中罕見的案例
就是這半年
穴道翻調的人真的是超級多
當然也不要因為說你沒有穴道翻調
就感覺到很
怎麼講
可能很生氣
或者說很遺憾或什麼的
你想嘛
你至少有買到大盤
大盤也50%
很誇張
你知道以前我們期待大盤一年是多少嗎
8-12%
以前我們期待大盤叫做8-12%
今年50%啦
所以知足常樂
下面一位
Benny AI
MK感恩愛您
本來前幾天還有很多問題想問
但這幾天抱著股票
越過山丘
才發現烏人燈喉
跌跌不休
事不活欲的哀愁
想說算了還是不問了
先躲進GG撐過去這段就好
PS好多拉麵明電撐不下去
陸陸續續要關了
希望MK林口造證計畫也有拉麵店
一樣我們不會主動去找案子
最主要就是剛好有一些對盤的東西
就是有機會誕生
最近我們確實是有一些新的機會
有可能會出現
再講說躲進去GG撐過去
對沒錯這個就是下很多人的想法
GG就是魔界2裡面的聖盔谷
大家發現說
你出事喔
洛翰的人民就會跑進去聖盔谷裡面
差不多這樣的感受
這時候就會想起媽媽的好
所以我之前跟大家講說
GG很像是你老媽
我覺得你平常都不會想到
你真的被女朋友甩了
你被你的上司羞辱了
或什麼你就會說
私上只有媽媽好我就會回去然後媽媽真的都表現得很好那下面一位L slash O哎大家好不知道這樣算不門留言成功了先五星吹小弟五月才開始認真聽您的Podcast大概從頭開始聽了160幾集
真的大大幫助了我的投資心法
這邊想請教
台股多久沒有進入一個真正的熊市
扣掉新冠的非系統性風險
或是川普關稅的低點
有可能出現一個回檔2萬點的熊市嗎
如果出現說明AI泡沫嗎
另外大熊餐廳第五季爆幹好看
推推我愛Carme
我愛Carme
那抓一大一家人身體健康平安順心
最近的熊市就是關稅那波就算了
因為熊市是有定義的
就是從高檔掉下來20%就算是一個熊市
那只是在過去的幾個熊市
除了2022以外
2025年的關稅
那時候營養師很深刻嘛
因為我的兒子剛好出生
我在醫院壓力很大
那2020年的肺炎
其實他們都算是recover很快的一個熊市
就是有進熊可是很快就出來了
2022我相信就是
就是從可能過去一路搞到現在的
近期最痛苦的應該是2022跟2018
因為這兩個持續的時間比較久
花了比較久去recover
所以他們也都算是雄士
然後是比較痛苦的
所以你說以現在來說回2萬點
2萬點的話差不多要回到4成多
有沒有可能發生
我覺得在不久的將來一定都是有機會
一定都是有機會
真的發生的時候該怎麼辦
就說明是AI碰碰碰
一定是AI泡沫
一定大家都會跟你說是AI泡沫
只是到時候就一樣
還是要去做一些見招拆招
因為你現在真的沒有辦法預期未來是怎麼樣
大家真的很喜歡去看預言家
只是你自己想想
你可能在2021 2020的時候
你真的也沒有辦法想到說
2023GPT會航空出世
一樣的道理你可能在2010的時候
你也沒有想到說
可能台灣的半導體後面有機會會整個大起飛
因為那時候甚至有一個說法是說
要去引一些中國的資金進來
不然我們就要玩蛋了什麼的
結果後來發現說
你跟中國站得越近你就越慘
所以其實有蠻多東西
你要看到牌子怎麼再去解會比較好
其實我真的覺得這個是
在實務上不管你做什麼工作
都該有的一個美德
就是你不要去當預言家
你不要去幻想
而是到底這個狀況是怎麼樣
出來之後你再去解它
那即便你可能會去承受一些傷害
只你要知道說大家也都會承受傷害
大盤回去的時候一定沒有人是好受的
那到時候再來說
就是你現在提早去做這樣子
一個規劃跟猜測都沒啥意義
因為其實在可能一兩萬點的時候
就一堆人會說會崩盤
一路崩到家四萬多點去了
你真的擔心40-50%的修正
你就再也不投資的話
如果40-50%修正是發生在
搞不好台股跑到5萬點或6萬點之後就像是可能我們早期的節目最近有些人會去把它highlight出來其實也是因為我們不預設高點以前可能會聊到說我們不知道大盤也會到什麼地方有些人就跑來去留言插旗說
你看一下大盤真的到什麼地方
其實那時候我們真的也不知道
都是見招拆招
可能也沒有想到說
我覺得東西可以走這麼遠之類的
只要它有辦法讓我們算到
後面的預期是好的
其實對我們來講
我們也比較不會去矛定說
過去買是曾經買過很便宜的數字
現在買不下去
你只要未來很好
其實我們都還是買下去
所以都是邊走邊看
提早去做這樣子猜測的意義不大
就像是可能那時候發生關稅之後
其實我相信也不是有多少人
有辦法去預測到說他可以recover這麼快
2022年可能很多人覺得會recover很快
因為那時候大家講說
物額戰爭過往對股市的影響都不會太久
不會太長就疊滿一整年
所以提早去猜沒有意義
只能夠跟你講說一定會有熊市
你死生一定會再遇到很多個熊市
你只要有心理準備就好
下面一位Eric Wang
主委有看過物語系列嗎
真的蠻好看的
然後想問幾歲會給小孩用AI呢
我小孩家就要用AI
他才40歲左右吧
當然我不知道去教育各位家長
怎麼樣去帶自己的小孩
我知道現在有很多家長是
跟我們的教育觀念不一樣
他們的小孩
第一個不能吃糖
第二個不能看電視
不可以使用iPad
不能用AI或啥小的
我的孩子是可以喝可樂的
適量就好
可以看iPad適量就好
可以看電視可以打電動
一樣適量就好
AI可以去做使用
我會認為說我就是要讓他會用
因為它到時候就是跑得比所有人更快
當然有些家長的想法是說
要用AI的腦袋會壞掉什麼
所以我就覺得家長的重點是你要去輔導
就是每個工具你給人家用到一個極限
可能真的都不是一個太好的事情
可能都會走偏掉
所以我是不會去反對任何新工具的
像我孩子現在就已經知道AI很強大
他就知道說Google
他就把它稱為是Google
Google可以去在睡前去生出一個故事
然後這故事還可以按照他要的條件去客製化
他覺得很有趣
但有時候他還是想去看一下傳統的故事書
因為這個劇情他覺得是比較有趣的
所以我盡量讓他去有這種多元的思維
就我也不會去灌輸他說
你一定要會使用AI
AI是他最屌 不是
AI就是他的一個工具箱裡面的工具
這個對我來講是育兒的方針
下面一位
前列線戰士
想請問主委曾經在EP457說過
觀察未來Token成本下降
會開始往軟體股佈局
目前是不是開始有這個跡象產生
另外也想問主委是怎麼樣決定
哪些公司要長期持有
像您的TESLA跟NVIDIA
因為聽起來光通部位已經降低
不過目前看起來光通敘事的
基本面都還沒有改變
首先
對我前面講的Token下降
一些軟體股的
他們的數字可能會開始變好
這個其實在最近的一些
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕